dr. Bryan Keating flew in this morning
just to give this talk his family is
building in Teton Village right now
which is his desire to get closer to the
community and he is has written a book
called losing the Nobel Prize and it was
one of the more interesting
technological academic approaches that
I've ever heard I've known him for a
number of years and I was just so
grateful that he was willing to come in
and people here know Brad Meade and who
has his own observatory in his home in
Jackson and Bryan has his own
observatory in his home in San Diego
there I said it again to Andy
but so Bryan thank you very much and
we're looking forward to Bryan become
and his family becoming very integrated
into the valley and into the community
it's a pleasure to be here and thank you
very much thank you Lee Brittany Spencer
especially governor Mead for being here
it's actually this is my 11th year
coming to Jackson halls so I am NOT a
novice in this valley and thankfully
I've never had to avail myself of any of
the medical services available here ok
well when I go down the ski mountains
I'm not that bad a skier but and I hope
never to but nevertheless we very much
enjoy being here and today I'm not gonna
talk about health although it might be a
little bit more morbid than anything
that you may have heard to date because
what I'm gonna talk about is something
sort of allied with with these prizes
that are given out and especially the
XPrize that Lee is so deeply involved
with and it really dates back to the
most prestigious accolade on earth which
is the Nobel Prize and we're in Nobel
Prize season and just the next week and
a half the winners of the 2018 Nobel
Prizes will be announced and the Nobel
Prizes sort of form a key theme may be a
villain sort of foe if you will in my
book losing the Nobel Prize which we
have free copies for all the attendees I
believe outside that the Nobel Prize
that has the capability to incentivize
very great things but also has some
powerful flaws in it that I think I was
able to identify during not one but
encounters with the Nobel Prize almost
winning it and subsequently losing it
spoiler alert but also being asked to
nominate the winners of the Nobel Prize
so that would be you know kind of like
the governor gets almost gets elected
and then the populace says can you
please tell us somebody better qualified
to be governor than yourself and that's
sort of what happened to me as I'll
explain here's the prize the actual
invention which was high technology in
the 1860s actually enabled us to build
even some of the connecting
infrastructure to Jackson Hall and that
was dynamite which was which was a key
invention predominately made for the
active war making war so the opposite of
why you guys are here you know happening
helping people live longer and better
lives but for a long time no bail and
his family were concerned with killing
people in fact so much so was the Nobel
name associated with death that in 1888
Alfred Nobel was walking around his
beloved streets of Paris where he had
become a voluntary refugee from from
Sweden where he grew up and he saw a
headline it said Alfred Nobel the
merchant of death is dead
and it called Alfred the person in
history had killed more people faster
more efficiently and quick or quickly
than any other person on earth now he's
reading this obituary right so as with
Mark Twain the reports of his demise
were slightly exaggerated but in this
case it was actually his older brother
brother Ludwig who had passed away and
yet it gave Alfred an opportunity to do
something very important to do what I
consider posthumous public-relations and
it really is as they mentioned is sort
of a McCobb team as in contre
distinction to the wonderful talks
you've heard the connection being
technology used to kill people and also
the morbidity factor that people don't
really consider until perhaps it's too
late so this event when Alfred read his
brother's obituary misattributed to him
it caused him to reevaluate his life and
much as George Bailey and it's a
wonderful life fantastic movie or
Ebenezer Scrooge in A Christmas Carol
these characters like alfred nobel
reevaluated their lives and they chose
to rehabilitate in their name by
dedicating it to service of the public
unfortunately since those a hundred and
twenty years since Alfred Nobel died the
Nobel Prizes strayed greatly from these
lofty visions and I'll talk about the
the kind of uncanny lessons that I take
away from it and I've been looking in
you know because of my relationship with
Lee and he's such a calm Buddhist type
that I thought I would actually bring
this connect this to a principle set of
principles from Buddhism that I recently
learned about aka on the flight over
here and that is that in Buddhism there
are four noble truths so there's the
Trinity in Christianity
there are similar things in Judaism and
Buddhism has the Four Noble Truths and I
think a lot of them apply to scientists
and engineers like myself who wish to
invent things create things and we
suffer from some of the pitfalls and
perils that the Buddha himself is
alleged to have alerted us to so the
first one very uplifting one is that all
life is misery okay that's really great
I tell that to my five kids every day
you know what they don't get what they
want I say well life is misery sorry son
the second truth is that the suffering
that we have is caused by cravings that
we might mount more money we might want
the more time we might want better
health and these are all considered
cravings and I think it's interesting
that the sort of path to enlightenment
which is sort of the the goal of
Buddhism which is which is number four
can be reached in a way that the Buddha
called the Eightfold way I actually
think that's a form of craving right
these Buddhists want to crave they crave
enlightenment now the question is
whether or not that craving leads to
step three or the third truth that you
can overcome these cravings by
introspection and contemplation of
course I'm playing on the Nobel versus
Noble Truths monikers but I want to take
you back to the first astrophysicist in
history who sketched something which
last year made quite a show over this
fine City and that was of course the
moon which brought a tremendous amount
of actually Astro tourism I'm sure the
governor can tell me how many how much
money was brought in to Jackson Hall it
was not only done for laypeople it was
actually for professional astronomers
like myself I received the list when I
told them I was going to meet with the
governor today I received a list of all
the observatories all the scientific
findings that resulted from this eclipse
and that's pretty amazing when you think
an astronomical event can cause with
thousands of tens of thousands of people
to converge spend money and do good
things here so I'm gonna work on trying
to get a neck and
klipsch in the next couple of years back
here so that you guys can you know
leverage the resources that you invested
but here's Galileo the first astronomer
in history who didn't invent the
telescope but he perfected it and he
used this device and treated it as a
monopoly to make discoveries that no
human being had ever seen before
picture on the lower right I actually
took myself from his famous book called
the Siderius nuncius the starry
messenger and that book is in in the
hands of a friend of mine at Williams
College in Western Massachusetts and I
spoke there last week and he let me take
it out and touch it and it was too big
to fit in my laptop bag otherwise we'd
have it here today but these simple
observations of the planet Jupiter and
its moons on the upper on the upper left
here this Illustrated that we lived in a
completely new paradigm that no one had
ever been aware of before but the
universe in which we inhabited was not
centred on us after all as much as we of
scientific variety have great egos we do
not inhabit what is truly the center of
the of the solar system nor do we
inhabit the center of the galaxy nor do
we inhabit the center of the universe
and now the question is do we inhabit
the center of what has become to be
called the multi-verse so we all know
there are many planets many stars many
galaxies what if there are many
universes and a core theme in my book is
how can we unravel whether or not this
is true whether or not we're not only
alone perhaps in the entire solar system
in terms of life but whether or not
we're accompanied throughout all of
space-time by other universes teeming
with life or perhaps sterile and barren
and those two possibilities I think are
just most fascinating things that you
can contemplate and we're actually
attacking that with technology and
resources in personnel that we have in
San Diego and and elsewhere around the
world literally on all seven continents
including Antarctica which I'll show you
a picture of the vision that Galileo
assured in was that the earth only
appears to be the center of a vast
network of what I call cosmic spheres
spheres that are apparitions that seem
to suggest that we are the center of the
earth that we are the center of the
solar system I mean it sure does appear
that the earth is flat
it sure does appear that the Sun rotates
around the earth it sure does appear
that we're at the center of the galaxy
but all of these are fallacies all of
these reflect biases in humanity's
perception of its own self-importance
and a lot of that has to do with the ego
which is part of what Buddhism as I
understand it from my 20 minutes
studying it has to do with overcoming to
and to get to this period of life called
enlightenment which I guess you just sit
cross-legged and meditate all the time
now we know that the universe actually
extends far beyond the things that
Galileo could see they extends back to
the first half million years after
what's called the Big Bang now we don't
know now whether or not the Big Bang is
the creation of time itself
or was merely merely the creation of the
part of the universe that we can observe
today nevertheless it's the farthest the
oldest point in time that we can see
back to and we use technology that I'll
explain very briefly I'm not going to
get into great details of it but it's
really just an upgrade to what Galileo
Galilei invented in 1609 are used in
1609 to disabuse us of our notion of
centrality and importance in the
universe I call Galileo the ultimate Big
Brother okay so so he's kind of the guy
says you're not that important you're
not that great you're not so you're not
so special that's really what he did he
assured in the notion that we're not the
center of anything other than our own
particular parochial sphere that we call
earth so what he hoped would happen was
this book would be make him world famous
that he would be renowned around the
world after showing it too early version
of the governors of northern Italy this
is in Venice outside Venice you can see
the the canals and so forth in the back
here he recognized that a lot of basic
technology that we do in physics leads
to applications in military applications
medical applications the very first
Nobel Prize won in Physics was awarded
to the inventor of the x-ray which went
from an invention in a laboratory not
unlike mine in San Diego this one was in
Austria and it was then used in research
visit oh sorry in physicians offices
around the world within weeks and of
course it benefited mankind in a
tremendous way so Alfred Nobel was
wildly successful he created this prize
to rehabilitate a name that had caused
death and destruction and become a
synonymous
with those two torturous aspects of
humanity and he made it into something
that saved lives around the world I
think it's quite fascinating of course
they're Nobel Prizes for medicine as
well so perhaps some of us in the
audience will aspire to such things
anyway he became wildly famous and for a
professor like me
I have great envy for him because he
immediately got tenure at the University
of Padua and not only that the chair of
his department doubled his start-up
funding so anyone who's a professor here
in the audience or recognize the
importance of those two things so this
is what he hoped would just keep keep on
happening he'd get he'd get a lot of
cash for it and he had a lot of
mistresses and illegitimate children to
support so this was no small detail for
the for the maestro as he was known but
instead of having this kind of a
reaction to his books he actually
suffered a lot worse he was actually put
on trial famously and forced to have
juror and des claim and and and say that
his findings on the Copernican model on
the earth on the sun-centered model of
the universe were accursed and basically
acts of the devil and although he is
claimed to have said under his breath
that I'm still right as they were about
to put him into prison the the Pope Pope
Urban who was depicted here very
friendly looking guy here and this is
that the Inquisition the so-called Holy
See Galilei was forced to recant and and
subjected to house imprisonment for the
last nine years of his life but they
couldn't contain his mind even though
his body was in prison he continued to
do research and actually came up with
primitive ways to tell time which sounds
primitive but back then there were no
such thing as watches smartwatches
healthwatches fitbit's and so forth they
didn't even have a reliable clock and he
came up with ways to do that using the
celestial spheres using maps of Jupiter
and its moons fascinating that you could
use things in space that had practical
benefits on earth and we like to think
that we're trying to extend Galileo's
mission not just beyond the spheres of
our celestial heavens here but all the
way back to the beginning of time
perhaps in a way that might illustrate
whether or not we are truly alone not
only amongst life-forms but what if
we're just one universe out of an
infinity of possible universe
and this relates to something called a
cosmic microwave background radiation
the light that I study you cannot see
with your eyes and nor can your iPhone
detect it instead what the image that
our telescopes capture are fluctuations
in the amount of matter and energy
present at the universe's first light
right after the first half a million
years which sounds like a long time but
we believe the universe is 13.8 to
billion years old give or take five or
ten years and that amount of time
elapsed the properties that we see today
were encoded encrypted in exactly the
same way that you features in some way
were encrypted by the smallest features
that you had as I often say we're trying
to divine an image of what the early
universe was like a trillionth of a
trillionth of a trillionth of a second
after the Big Bang and doing that is far
harder it's actually a billion billion
billion billion times harder than trying
to do this which is taking image which
you doctor eggheads will notice is a
blastocyst or a human embryonic stem
cell collection it's an embryo that
represents the way you looked about a
thousand seconds as I always say after
your parents have their own personal Big
Bang that thousand second period after
the creation or conception event you
were collection about 200 stem cells now
what would you expect this this stem
cell embryo would evolve into well I
don't expect you to guess just by seeing
it but I'll add some identifying
features and then you may recognize it
as none other than my children's
favorite astrophysicist Neil deGrasse
Tyson so we're trying to figure out if
you're trying to figure out what did
Neil look like when he was an embryo a
thousand seconds after conception
knowing that he's about 2 billion
seconds old they won't feel old culture
age in seconds and quote it in billions
of seconds you'll sound really old so
those of you on the verge of your 21st
birthday are about 800 million seconds
old or so so so try that as a fun
exercise but we're trying to go way back
in time the way that we do that is we
built a telescope and the goal of the
telescope was not only to see the Big
Bang but to be honest with you one of my
motivations in creating it was to win
these prizes here I craved these prizes
so Buddha would say you know strike two
and you know nothing good is going to
come of it
because this is the most tangible reward
I would say in all of humanity I would
say that across the planet there's no
greater distinction honor accolade or
prize sorry Lee in the XPrize then
winning the Nobel Prize in fact some
people have won prizes worth far more
money called the breakthrough prize have
said things like I'll trade it in for a
Nobel Prize even though it's worth three
million dollars more than the Nobel
Prize so why is that what does it become
that makes it so prestigious well we had
our eyes trained on this prize we
invented a telescope that's very much
like Galileo's telescope in other words
it just used lenses and instead of
connecting it to his eye it connected to
a set of sensors made of what are called
called transition edge sensors
superconducting bolometer --zz which is
really just a fancy way of saying heat
detectors so just as you can detect
where the Sun is with your eyes closed
and waving your hand around these
detectors can detect those patterns of
microwaves to which our eyes are blind
so we invented these tech detectors and
there's only 256 of them which sounds
puny compared to your iPhone which has
millions of them but unlike your iPhone
you know we don't void our warranty when
we cool it down to four hundred and
fifty four degrees below zero Fahrenheit
okay so that's almost five hundred
degrees colder than this room is right
now and if you could turn it down and
make me feel really comfortable that
would be great no I'm just kidding I'm
fine this detector system we had to take
somewhere very special I'd love to take
it here and put it on Grand Targhee but
the governor wouldn't approve of it
instead we took this whole telescope
which is about ten feet tall weighs
about 15,000 pounds we disassembled it
put it inside of cargo planes and took
it to the very bottom of the world a
forbidding place called the South Pole
Antarctica there it is and technology is
really the key to Antarctica and it was
really the site of the world's first
arms race or space race or technology
race 105 years ago when two teams of
explorers one led by Roald Amundsen it
was a Norwegian explorer and another led
by a British explorer named Robert
Falcon Scott coolest middle name ever
tried to convince my wife to name our
most recent son Falcon that she'd the
mirrored anyway they had two different
approaches technologically wouldn't you
say so the Norwegian team made use of a
very ancient technology but well proven
well understood called dogs
said the brits who knew that they would
have to do what their Norwegians would
do which is eat the dogs when they got
to the South Pole they refused to do
that they said we're Brits after all we
have stiff upper lips but they're not
that stiff they refused to eat the dogs
they said we'll be the beasts of burden
that cost them all their lives all these
guys died getting to the South Pole just
a mere three weeks after the Norwegian
team made first landfall there and this
is no small feat imagine going from sea
level to the top of Targhee or something
like that 10,000 feet over a course of
700 nautical miles on foot or on skis
and it's not groomed powder like we have
on some runs here it's frozen waves of
snow predominantly when Falcon and his
team got there they saw a Norwegian flag
what must have that have felt like well
I liken it to Neil Armstrong stepping
out of the Eagle on - or a Soviet flag a
Russian flag not just a sense of
disappointment national prestige human
lives at stake and lost because of this
technology shortfall this lack of vision
and foresight so that costs them their
lives and it's very dangerous to go to
the Antarctic today as I will depict
here this is for my last voyage down
there so my five-year-old son he wanted
me to bring him back to penguin if I
said of course
it could be easier than Catterick
capturing a penguin they can't even fly
and this one's on land so I figured I'd
go up to him one of my students told me
okay so beware of penguins they are not
the cuddly creatures that you've come to
expect
instead of getting there by foot we now
take US military cargo planes which fly
us from the southern island of New
Zealand in town called Christchurch and
fly us all the way down to the South
Pole more or less over a period of time
that takes about 11 hours just to get to
the coast of Antarctica and that 11 hour
flight is very comfortable as you can
see here you know this is like the
American Airlines flight getting over
here the passenger sit need a knee and
you're only afforded a one sack of lunch
and it can have any number of different
animals that were used to make that
lunch you don't want to ask fewer
questions the better you notice there's
almost no windows here there are almost
no windows for passengers on this side
over here because it's almost nothing to
see except blinding white ice this is
the by the way this is the President's
Club
over here this is the Admirals Club this
first class business class lift when you
land at the South Pole you see this
fabulous passenger terminal called the
South Pole international passenger
terminal or the services are rather
incomplete and the Wi-Fi is spotty to
say the least now you're wearing now
you're about negative 30 Fahrenheit or
so and once you get out here it's quite
cold here are the waves of snow that
these guys had to climb over to get to
the South Pole and kind of shown to
scale so it's not like a groomed
cross-country powder that you might
enjoy here here's me taking a selfie put
on Facebook when I got there the first
time I went there been there twice and
we went there to build this telescope
called bicep - bicep - as features that
allow it to see back to the very
beginning of time and so we thought we'd
be quite successful perhaps even even
garnering the most prestigious award
known to man as I said the Nobel Prize
in fact we did it we announced we made a
discovery for technical reasons I
described it very good detail in the
book we we found a signal and we found
this signal the exact signal we were
looking for and that's kind of scary in
some sense when you find what you're
looking for it can mean one of two
things you're right and you're gonna
celebrate or you were serving to confirm
your biases and you found something
which was just a mirage so which one was
it
well the media took a great interest in
our discovery because it spoke to the
most ancient of human questions which is
how do we get here how did the universe
come to be and you can see headlines
that were really broadcast around the
world this is from Harvard we had a
video that we released one of the team
members at Stanford release that got
three million views almost in a day this
is big for science this is not a
Kardashian you know new fragrance this
is you know kind of nerdy technical
scientists doing something that requires
a lot of explanation in fact it was on
the front page of the newspaper of
record the one that prints all news fit
to print yes the San Diego union-tribune
I welcome you I was probably in the
newspaper here it was on the front page
of the New York Times I just had
breakfast last week with the author
Dennis Overby I like this headline The
Economist just like some guy suddenly
saw the start of the universe yeah
that's awesome
at least that's the implication and of
course the greatest scientific journal
of record is none other than the onion
who actually did a good job on there
story they said theoretical physicist
and R&B singers met to debate the
meaning of forever and it says down here
there's Aretha Franklin the late great
Aretha Franklin physicist Smokey
Robinson
it says panelists discussed whether it
is theoretically possible to give you my
heart forever so we didn't answer that
question and unfortunately as you might
guess from the title of my book it was
not to be the discovery that we thought
we had made one for the ages that
garnered so much fame fortune and
presumably an answer an itch to the
craving that I had had for decades was
not to be in fact instead of seeing the
birth pangs of the Big Bang we saw
nothing but tiny grains of dust
suspended amidst the stars in the Milky
Way's magnetic fields a different type
of science an interesting form of
science but not what we expected to see
and soon after we had to retract our
discovery instead of seeing the universe
through these pristine lenses envisioned
all the way back to the beginning of
time
no now we know the universe is basically
a pretty polluted place but it's not all
bad news because without that pollution
that pollution is actually the stuff
that makes up the earth it's the same
carbon nitrogen it's the same iron
nickel and silicon that makes up the
mountains that were sitting on so
without it we wouldn't be here but it
does get in the way of Nobel prizes
so that craving went away and then I was
overcome with a sense of embarrassment
to add to my humiliation which is that
the next day basically after getting
this the retraction issuing this
retraction more or less I received a
letter from the Swedish Academy of Art
of Sciences inviting me to make a
nomination for the Nobel Prize in
Physics for the very year I had hoped I
would might win it so again this is like
you know if you're a realtor someone
doesn't want to use your services asks
you to recommend a better realtor and
that's what I had the honor of doing and
it set me out on a quest you know it's
kind of a nerdy academician scholar I
went off and did an investigation as to
what Alfred Nobel really wanted why did
he make this Prize what was it for and
that set me off on a path of discovery
which led to the second notion of the
title of my book which is losing the
Nobel Prize and that is whether or not
the Nobel Prize itself needs to be
gotten rid of at least in its current
form
oh by the way I'm asking you all to keep
this strictly confidential okay don't
tell anybody so they asked me to do that
but I put it in my book anyway I went
back to Alfred Nobel's original will and
speaking fluent Swedish as I know we all
do we can read it it says here I Alfred
Nobel want my entire estate to be
annually distributed in the form of
prizes to those who have made the
greatest benefit to mankind now this is
a person who invented dynamite three
hundred and fifty four other patents he
was a known inventor and he wanted to
cause inventions to make things better
on earth the question is is that doing
that is it actually conferring benefit
on mankind so I go through not eight
ways to enlightenment I go through five
different pathways in my book and I'm
almost out of time and I want to leave
time for thunderous applause so I'll
stop soon but but the prize really this
encounter with it actually I don't know
why this is cut off but it's probably a
PowerPoint conversion issue it says here
this is a Mahatma Gandhi by the way he
was nominated for the Nobel Peace Prize
the same exact number of times as Adolf
Hitler so isn't that wonderful so one of
the greatest humanitarians on earth
unfortunately never won it thank God
Alfred Hitler never won it either but he
said before he lost his own Nobel Prize
he said the seeker after truth must be
humbler than the dust because although
the world crushes dust under its feet we
should think that dust could crush us
and what a perfect metaphor for what we
did and what we saw we thought we were
seeing this thing that would bring us
worldwide acclaim that we craved instead
it humbled us but it put us on a pathway
to invent new and better technology I'll
just close with the statement revolving
around this will which is that so we
just had Yom Kippur for those of us who
are Jewish yesterday and one of the
sayings caught my eye in the in the
prayer book services and it said repent
one day before your death and so of
course you don't know when you're gonna
die so you should repent you should have
this sense of humility and leave an
ethical will behind for yourself well
Jesus did it Moses did it and Barack
Obama did it and many of the great
leaders and thinkers in history have
done it and it's one of the most
greatest gifts you can give to your
children and their grandchildren after
all think about it what if you have kids
or grandkids and what if you have know
that somewhere wait
back in history your beloved
great-grandfather wrote a book and in
that book were described his secrets or
your grandmother her secrets and words
of wisdom for life how much would you
pay for that book well you'll be able to
get mine for free outside but think
about leaving a legacy and that's part
of what I think we should all do and pay
heed to so I'll leave you with that
happy to take questions I guess we might
be a couple minutes overtime but thank
you very much for having me out here
[Applause]
guys are worse than my students okay
it's the high altitude oh yes over there
ah I can nominated someone who's my
oldest son would say the name is nunya
nunya business so I don't tell in the
book because the person or persons may
or may not still be alive and according
to the rules of the Nobel foundation
they could still be nominated so even
though I have misgivings about it I
didn't want to scuttle his or her
chances but you might be able to divine
from the description in the book who I
might have nominated because I do give
some hints to it yeah right here
absolutely yes
[Music]
absolutely so the question is whether or
not the ethical kind of best practices
within science assuming that they're not
compromised themselves as a questioner
alluded to if those can be applied to
society at large the scientific method
in my opinion is the greatest invention
that's ever been made greater than the
telescope greater than the lighthouse
which won the Nobel Prize in 1911 these
are these are inventions that allow us
to save time to ensure quality and to
ensure that best the the best and
greatest minds and and representation
from all around the world and different
corners of the world are represented so
we don't want to miss out on the next
Einstein but a lot of what's happening
in science right now is really not fully
in court encompassing the panorama that
science truly is some of that in my
opinion is caused by the Nobel Prize in
this fixation only three people can win
it my experiment had 50 people the
current experiment I'm leading has 255
and the experiment that won at last year
had a thousand people on it now how do
you pick 3 people at most which Alfred
Nobel you know didn't even approve of
how do you do that and and not leave out
broad swaths of humanity so there are
ways in the book I describe how we can
apply the tools of the scientific method
to ensure ethical best practices are met
yeah in the back in 20 years where do I
see the field so so I one of the funders
of my experiment is a billionaire in New
York City named Jim Simons and he asked
me that he asked me a question when he's
gonna make your discovery and I said you
know maybe in 20 years we'll rewrite the
history book and your name will because
he's like make it 5 okay so the the
hardest thing to do is to make
predictions about what will happen in
the future as Yogi Berra said right
they're particularly difficult but in in
my mind what we are going to do is
equally equivalent and not just me
there's much much smarter people
my students and co-workers that we can
make a revolution perhaps that tells us
how the universe came to be and what if
anything have you ever thought what came
before the Big Bang
have you ever thought are there other
universes out there besides art so art
groups are trying to blend the
technology the brainpower the
computational horsepower that we have to
take steps to understand what happened
15 minutes before the Big Bang I most
want to answer that question I believe
we'll have some inkling of the answer to
that question within 20 years it's a
question up there right here yeah yeah
so the question is if Nobel were alive
today would he be upset at the what's
become of the prize well I'll say two
things one is that he made it very clear
what he wants in his will and I
described that in the book so by the way
the book is mostly about a memoir of
cosmology there are three chapters about
the Nobel Prize those are color-coded so
you can skip them if you don't care but
if you do care I talked about how an
estate lawyer would prosecute the
executor zuv the Nobel Prize because
what they've done is completely
transgress what he wanted which was that
a prize should be given to a single
person who made an invention or
discovery in the preceding year that
caused the greatest benefit to humankind
now I go through those different three
things I call those broken lenses of the
Nobel Prize and what he would most be
shocked about is that we're giving
awards for things that were done decades
ago to groups of three people not one
person and some of the awards that we're
giving it's questionable five years ago
the Nobel Prize went for the discovery
of the Higgs boson may or may not know
that in fact you probably don't know
that which shows how much of a benefit
did it cost to humankind in fact I would
worry for you if you told me the Higgs
bosons really important to my daily life
you know I mean even a physicist doesn't
care about that much but the number one
thing I think he would be rolling over
in his grave quite quite literally and
he was worried about being buried alive
and he took straight steps to make sure
he was dead dead is that once you're so
in my religion Judaism if you the
highest mitzvot the highest good deed
you can do is take care of someone who's
dead because you're doing it completely
selfless
they can't do anything to repay you for
taking care of their dead body right so
in this case they caught the comp
travailing worse sin you can do is go
against what a person wanted explicitly
because there's nothing they can do and
so we should uphold what Alfred Nobel
wanted so I think he'd be spending his
ashes would be stupid he got cremated
and he also got his bled out so he was
an interesting guy
so I think he'd be appalled in some
sense yeah no Fermi's paradox
fascinating so Fermi's paradox suggests
that there are literally trillions of
planets perhaps in our own galaxy there
are probably half a trillion galaxies
that we keep that we can eventually see
in our observable universe each one with
a trillion planets within it the
question and reconfirm a winner of the
1943 Nobel Prize in Physics he
conjectured if there's so many planets
then even if only one in a trillion have
planets there's trillions and trillions
of planets in the in the known universe
there should be trillions of other
life-forms they should have been here by
now and yet we have zero credible
evidence for it despite the close
encounters that took place not far from
here right come on you guys should get
that right Close Encounters come on
nevertheless we have zero evidence for
the existence of other life and in fact
depressingly I just finished a book by a
co-author at my publisher Norton named
Adam Frank where he says that we have to
stop really looking for actual
technology with et you know beaming us
messages are getting close encounters in
some other way but instead we have to
look for the byproducts of of an its
civilization so look for global warming
on planet blook on in the Andromeda
galaxy so it's gone beyond it's gotten
so depressing for these people I feel
sorry for them they haven't seen any
evidence of it and they've only to be
fair basically skimmed one capful of
water out of the Pacific Ocean in terms
of how much could be explored in this in
the universe and just our observable
universe so I think it's currently very
depressing that the status of Fermi's
paradox
it sure doesn't appear and the
conditions don't seem to be right but
the numbers are overwhelming yep
I would like to go back I would like to
go back to Antarctica what surprised me
so much about it was the desolation and
the other worldliness of being on this
frozen outpost literally at the bottom
of the world and the other thing that
surprised me I'm a terrible Ronda I'm
pretty out of shape but I literally ran
around the world in under a minute
so that was pretty cool the other thing
that was otherworldly about is that the
Sun never sets at the South Pole it set
sorry once a year it sets so it's
actually coming up tomorrow at the South
Pole my friend who runs our observatory
he's been there for a year I tricked him
into going down there I said I'll give
you 75 thousand dollars for one night of
work and he bought it so he's been there
he's and they don't know where the Sun
is gonna come up it's a maze gonna come
up in the east what's in the where's the
East at the South Pole
it's not defined we don't know it's like
what happened before time existed does
that make sense
so there are all sorts of just
otherworldly phenomena I witnessed that
it was really a blessing to go down
there okay last question any burning
questions okay so they're copies of the
book outside I believe yeah thank you
guys very much
[Applause]